INCLUDING EXTRADITION THAT MAY
GO WELL BEYOND THE TRUMP
PRESIDENCY.
>> Bret: PRESIDENT TRUMP IS
NOT SAYING MUCH TODAY IN
REACTION TO THE ASSANGE THE
REST.
SHE WHITE HOUSE CORRESPONDENT
JOHN ROBERTS IS AT THE
WHITE HOUSE TONIGHT.
>> IN THE OVAL OFFICE,
PRESIDENTS
>> I KNOW NOTHING ABOUT
WIKILEAKS.
IT'S NOT MY THING.
I KNOW THERE IS SOMETHING HAVING
TO DO WITH JULIAN ASSANGE.
I KNOW NOTHING REALLY ABOUT HIM.
IT'S NOT MY DEAL IN LIFE.
>> DURING THE 2016 CAMPAIGN, THE
PRESIDENT HAD PLENTY TO SAY
ABOUT WIKILEAKS.
>> I LOVE WIKILEAKS!
SOME BRUTAL STUFF, I'D READ IT
TO YOU.
WIKILEAKS UNVEILS HORRIBLE,
HORRIBLE THINGS ABOUT HE REALLY
CLINTON.
WIKILEAKS IS AMAZING, SHOWS
SHE'S A REAL LIAR.
WIKILEAKS HAS DONE A JOB ON HER.
>> IT'S UNCLEAR WHY ECUADOR
SUDDENLY DECIDED TO EVICT JULIAN
ASSANGE, BUT TWO COCHLEAR EVENTS
IN THE TIMELINE, THE FINDING OF
NO COLLUSION BY THE MUELLER
INVESTIGATION, AND LAST JULY'S
TRIP TO MEET THE NEW PRESIDENT
OF ECUADOR, WHERE THE TWO
LEADERS DISCUSSED BARR'S ALLEGED
CRIMES.
>> THE UNITED STATES HAS ALWAYS
CHERISHED OUR RELATIONSHIP WITH
THE ECUADORIANS.
AND WE ARE DETERMINED TO RENEW
THAT RELATIONSHIP FOR THE MUTUAL
BENEFIT OF BOTH OUR NATIONS.
>> THE PRESIDENT SAYS HE TRUST
ATTORNEY GENERAL WILLIAM BARR TO
HANDLE THE ASSANGE CASE
APPROPRIATELY.
>> THAT WOULD BE A DETERMINATION
MOSTLY I BELIEVE BY THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL WHO IS DOING AN
EXCELLENT JOB, SO HE'LL BE
MAKING A DETERMINATION.
>> Bret:
>> PRESIDENT TRUMP ALSO WAITED
ON ATTORNEY GENERAL BARR'S
ASSERTION THAT THE TRUMP
CAMPAIGN HAD BEEN SPIED ON.
>> WHAT HE SAID WAS ABSOLUTELY
TRUE AND THERE WAS ABSOLUTELY
SPYING INTO MY CAMPAIGN.
I WILL GO A STEP FURTHER IN MY
OPINION IT WAS ILLEGAL SPYING,
UNPRECEDENTED SPYING.
SOMETHING THAT SHOULD NEVER BE
ALLOWED TO HAPPEN TO OUR COUNTRY
AGAIN.
I THINK HIS ANSWER WAS ACTUALLY
IN A VERY ACCURATE ONE.
THIS IS VERY POLITICS.
THIS IS ACTUALLY TREASON.
>> ON NORTH KOREA, PRESIDENT
SAID THAT SANCTIONS WILL STAY
ON, BUT HE'S OPEN TO SOMEHOW
MARRIED SOME HUMANITARIAN
ASSISTANCE FOR NORTH AMERICA
NORTH
HUMANITARIAN ASSISTANCE FOR
NORTH KOREA.
HE MAY BE WILLING TO CONSIDER
SOUTH KOREA'S CONCEPTION OF
SMALLER DEALS TO KEEP UP
MOMENTUM.
>> THINGS CAN HAPPEN.
YOU CAN WORK OUT PIECE BY PIECES
PIECES.
THE BIG DEAL AS WE HAVE TO GET
RID OF THE NUCLEAR WEAPONS.
>> PRESIDENT TRUMP CONTINUES TO
HOLD OUT AND ALL OF BRANCH TO
NORTH KOREA, KIM JONG UN TALKING
ABOUT THE ECONOMIC POTENTIAL OF
A NORTH KOREA WITHOUT NUCLEAR